la prostitution officiellement interdite
aux Émirats mais pourtant tolérés à
Dubaï a fait de cette ville la
principale destination en matière de
tourisme sexuel c'est que des
influenceuses des stars de téléréalité
venus s'installer en nombre ces
dernières années n'ayant rien à ranger
l'image sulfureuse de Dubaï je me suis
posé 10 minutes dans un hôtel le premier
mec qui est rentré il m'a pris m'a parlé
moi j'y vais en montre ses banques
dernière polémique en date le
porte-à-poticate ou le scandale des
escort-girls considéré comme des WC
ambulants sur la vidéo qui circule cette
semaine on peut voir un homme faisant
caca dans la bouche d'une femme
plusieurs blogueurs ont révélé sur leur
chaîne que certaines influenceuses ça
donnerait à des pratiques scatophiles
pour assouvir le fantasme de Rich
milliardaire tu faisais escort manger
caca de gros monsieur certaines d'entre
elles pourraient empocher jusqu'à 20000
euros pour subir de telles humiliations
physiques d'autres pratiques comme la
zoophilie ou encore la pédophilie sont
évoquées alors os de la prostitution et
ses dérives les influenceuses de Dubaï
réalise-t-elle des choses immondes pour
devenir riche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'être avec nous candidate de
télé-réalité maïsson qui va souvent nous
voir merci on aimerait que vous nous
éclairiez là-dessus je sais que
Guillaume a énormément de choses
là-dessus je sais que Benjamin également
enquêter voilà qui était en fait tout a
commencé il y a 4 mois c'est un
youtubeur anglais qui a fait une vidéo
en disant que certaines jeunes femmes à
Dubaï avaient recours à ce genre de
pratique pour illustrer la vidéo il a
mis des photos regardez de de candidats
de français dans l'occurrence les
jumelles Elmer mais aussi minage Yasmine
suite à ça il y a un blogueur qui
s'appelle aquabeke c'est en parler de
l'affaire qui enquête depuis longtemps
sur les rumeurs de prostitution dans la
téléréalité entre temps ce youtubeur
anglais a mis une autre vidéo un
commentaire pour dire que ces photos en
fait il les avait juste mises pour
illustrer le sujet et qui ne les
connaissait pas personnellement d'accord
voilà aujourd'hui ces paroles contre
parole les influenceurs en question
disent qu'elles vont attaquer toutes les
personnes qui les dénigres parce
qu'elles sont victimes de harcèlement et
le blogueur aquarium dit lui qu'il a des
preuves concrètes c'est ça qu'on attend
des profs concrètes d'accord parce que
Maëva elle fait pas ça du tout voilà il
y a aucune preuve concrète aujourd'hui
ce sont que des rumeurs après il y a des
gens qui affirment détenir des preuves
et c'est ça qu'il faut sortir si c'est
le cas si c'est regardez alors il y a
deux choses il y a d'abord comment ça se
passait donc là-bas elles étaient
recrutées pour des soirées elle ne
savait pas forcément que des pratiques
scabreuses ou délirantes allaient se
produire elles arrivaient dans une
chambre après avoir rendez-vous avec un
milliardaire et elle se trouvait souvent
face à quatre hommes des gardes du corps
et était forcées à des choses et pour
les forcer parfois elles étaient
droguées donc après il y avait
effectivement
d'effécation sur elle
forcer à manger leur vomi des rapports
sexuels avec des animaux non et le chant
et le chantage c'était le chantage
c'était drogue et on confie ce que les
papiers on leur confisquerait leurs
papiers comme il y avait plusieurs
hommes parfois il y avait même des
pratiques avec plusieurs hommes alors je
vais vous donner je vais vous ce qui est
sorti on a travaillé avec Guillaume il y
a une liste que notamment
je précise que cette liste que je vais
vous donner de nom tout le monde dément
et que c'est une liste de personnes qui
auraient été Jean-Paul conditionnel qui
aurait été escorte d'accord c'est pas
forcément des gens qui se sera livrés à
ces pratiques scabreuses mais néanmoins
c'est une liste de gens qui auraient été
véridique ou pas ces gens démontent mais
c'est liste circulent c'est comme vous
voulez je peux vous donner les noms des
gens qui sont cités entre Paris et Dubaï
pour cette potentiellement
je vous la montre ça commence là
[Rires]
alors il y a il y a il y a pour beaucoup
dans ces pratiques scabreuses il y a
pour beaucoup des agressions et je vais
même vous dire
[Musique]
non mais non voilà on va pas non mais
donne pas demandé d'agressions elles ont
porté plainte parce qu'on sait si comme
vous voulez bon alors il y a des
escortes d'avant et il y a des escorts
d'aujourd'hui et je vais aussi vous
révéler quelque chose c'est que j'ai
parlé aujourd'hui avec un influenceur il
est révérant protestant et influenceur
africain il est à en Côte d'Ivoire
Camille Makosso il m'a révélé qu'il y
avait 1000 femmes africaines mille
femmes africaines qui étaient recrutés
notamment par un réseau Tik Tok pour
être
esclave sexuel à Dubaï il y a trois
jeunes femmes camerounaises qui ont
disparu il y a eu un suicide c'est des
Miss des mannequins des actrices
Cameroun Côte d'Ivoire Sénégal plein de
pays il est effrayé il y a un réseau il
y a des humiliations racistes et lui il
se mobilise pour que ça cesse c'est une
pratique alors on donne pas de nom mais
honnêtement Cyril c'est une pratique qui
est en train de prendre une expansion
incroyable délirante folle et
scandaleuse à Dubaï alors Maïssa est
avec nous est-ce qu'on vous a déjà
proposé de vous payer pour de faire des
choses sexuelles mais c'est vrai que
nous en tant que candidate de télé on
reçoit souvent des propositions qui sont
assez avec des sommes assez
astronomiques ça c'est vrai ça nous
arrive souvent genre on reçoit des trucs
pour envoyer des photos des photos de
pieds ou pour
faire des trucs chelous
quoi
souvent des propositions
jusqu'à 5000 euros pour une photo de
pieds
dans la gueule
5000 euros pour des photocopies on vous
a pas demandé des photos dénudées aussi
oui ça ça on reçoit tout le temps
effectivement
[Rires]
et vous
qu'est-ce que vous a demandé de faire
c'est sur les réseaux c'est sur les
réseaux on reçoit des mails après je
pense que nous justement dans le monde
de la télé-réalité on est des femmes qui
gagnent quand même assez bien notre vie
pour pas avoir on n'est pas dans le
besoin donc on n'a pas besoin justement
de devoir envoyer des photos de dénudés
de nous et je trouve ça dommage que
justement cette image là d'escorte elle
soit associée à notre image sous
prétexte que les gens sont pas capables
d'accepter qu'on peut s'acheter des sacs
de luxe ou rouler en grosse voiture sans
forcément se prostituer donc je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de fantasmes autour
de ça il y a beaucoup de mensonges après
les propositions c'est sûr qu'on les
reçoit on en reçoit plein quoi c'est à
dire toutes les semaines on doit
recevoir toutes les semaines
d'escortes de Dubaï qui nous envoient
des qui nous envoient des mails
trucs comme ça ben c'est jamais écrit
dans le mail parce que c'est pas
des soirées non pour venir faire un
voyage accompagner des hommes
c'est incroyable ça et combien vous
propose quand même pour un voyage comme
ça je sais pas le dernier mail que j'ai
reçu ça doit être 50 000 euros pour
faire un voyage une semaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu penses que les candidats
ont déjà participé à ce genre de truc ou
pas du tout tu sais pas te poser c'est
des débats qu'on a forcément entre nous
quand on a quand on quand on est en
tournage etc
à chaque fois on a tout on a toute la
même réflexion en disant que en fait
c'est juste les gens qui de l'extérieur
qui voient notre train de vie et qui
peuvent s'expliquer que notre train de
vie en disant que forcément on se
prostitue mais c'est pas le cas moi j'ai
jamais entendu personne en tout cas
assumer j'ai jamais vu personne de mes
yeux le faire et surtout moi je sais
très bien le nombre de propositions que
je refuse avec que je regarde même pas
je veux dire toute la vérité cette
affaire de prostitution alors les les
déviance on l'a appris il y a deux trois
ans mais la prostitution dans la
télé-réalité je peux vous révéler
quelque chose de très fort c'est que à
l'époque de Secret Story quand on veut
des castings il y avait un code qu'on
donnait aux filles qui passaient les
casting attention code Dubaï on savait
très bien pour certaines d'entre elles
que leur métier était aussi d'aller
faire des voyages à Dubaï pour faire ce
métier donc de call-girls alors c'est
vrai que moi ici pour le casting aussi
de TPMP j'ai un code Cergy-Pontoise
je peux même bourrer je peux même vous
révéler autre chose c'est que sur le sur
l'émission comme c'était filmé 24 heures
sur 24
certains certaines candidates se
parlaient pensant être pas filmés et
échanger dans une langue étrangère et on
a fait traduire et on a compris très
vite que leur métier essentiel était
effectivement d'être call-girl c'est
incroyable à tel point que certaines
candidates ont décidé de quitter le
programme pas parce qu'elles étaient
soi-disant en dépression mais parce que
elle avait fait le calcul qu'en restant
deux semaines ou trois semaines avec
nous elle perdait une tonne d'oseille
donc ce dossier là est un dossier connu
et très connu dans le monde de la
téléréalité de mon époque pour parler
comme un comme un vieux con mais
effectivement la transhumance Paris
Dubaï dont on parle aujourd'hui date
effectivement de l'époque de Secret
Story parce que il y avait effectivement
alors je peux pas de trafic parce que
elles étaient consciente c'est leur
métier voilà c'est un métier et vous
allez beaucoup travailler là-bas
aujourd'hui je les connais pas mais si
ça existait il y a 10 ans je vois pas
pourquoi maintenant ça réduit
et empire et après pour cette affaire
dont on a parlé de déviance dégueulasse
etc oui on a entendu parler
effectivement des listes de noms sont
mais là c'est sur des rumeurs donc ça a
pas été vérifié et des gens extrêmement
connus télé-réalité
c'est parce qu'elles ont été dans un
programme de télé-réalité pour leur à
proposer et qu'elles ont cédé où est-ce
qu'elles étaient avant
quand tu fais un casting voilà il large
donc ils vont sur les réseaux à l'époque
ils allaient sur my space ils allaient
sur sur tout ce qu'ils peuvent servir
pour voir donc effectivement parfois il
menait des enquêtes parfois il trouvait
très vite que c'était pas possible pour
le programme et puis parfois on a
découvert pendant le programme mais
c'est un vieux dossier et je vous dis
très c'est très connu voilà très connu
c'est fou ça Valérie ça va dans les deux
sens c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des escorts
qui deviennent candidate il y a des
candidats qui deviennent des sortes
comment ça se passe en fait elles sont
très médiatisées à la télé avant
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux il y a des
hommes d'affaires qui les voient qui
disent à leurs équipes elles vont me la
mettez vous la mettez dans un dans un
jet elle les rejoignent avec leurs amis
et c'est comme ça que ça se passe et la
ligne de défense de ces femmes qui sont
accusées de ces pratiques dégueulasses
c'est que ce serait de la jalousie et
que les gens essayaient de justifier des
revenus démesurés parce qu'il y a des
gens qui gagnent 100.000 300.000 euros
en disant c'est pas avec les placements
de produits mais c'est en pratiquant ce
genre de de ça voilà c'est ce que disait
non c'est vrai c'est ce que disait
maïssan il y a 2 secondes il disait
voilà c'est à dire que les gens ont
voient un train de vie incroyable ils se
disent à mon avis elle doit être forte
également c'est ça c'est ce qui c'est le
oui moi je juge pas mais ça me fait
vraiment beaucoup de peine je trouve ça
évidemment désolant et je trouve que
c'est bien aujourd'hui qu'on montre
qu'on le dise et qu'il y ait une sorte
de Me Too influenceuse à Dubaï parce que
évidemment il s'agit pas de jeter le
discrédit sur toute une profession mais
malgré tout il y a un truc qui est très
malsain c'est pas du tout un cercle
vertueux c'est un cercle complètement
vicieux et complètement dégueulasse où
on montre des villas Luke des sacs de
Luke des voitures de luxe et tout ça et
il y a des jeunes filles pardon mais qui
sont complètement bernées qui tombent
dans le système et je sais bien qu'il y
a des des filles qui sont call-girl et
le veulent bien mais quand on va là-bas
et qu'on attrape une MST quand il y a du
trafic d'organes qu'on ne vole tes
papiers moi pardon mais on joue sur la
naïveté des filles qui rêve de devenir
des influences des influenceuses comme
ça avec des piscines à débordement et
des limous mais c'est pas ça la vraie
vie il faut faire quand même très très
attention
tu as jamais entendu parler de ça toi tu
as entendu parler mais pas on en a
toujours entendu parler mais ça pour
nous qui sommes dans le milieu on sait
très bien que dès l'instant où on a un
pied dehors on est pris en photo on fait
un pas travers on est prêt en photo on
se tâche le t-shirt on est pris en photo
donc comment c'est possible qu'il y ait
jamais aucune preuve qui soit sorti qui
est jamais eu aucune photo aucun
document officiel ou qu'on ait vu
personne peut faire tomber tout le monde
parce qu'en fait tout le monde
quel système aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux c'est ton père
ce sont des réseaux vous parlez de
réseaux sociaux ce sont des réseaux de
prostitution très organisées avec
parfois des menaces et et moi quelqu'un
m'a dit qu'il y a des tarifs spécifiques
pour faire l'amour à plusieurs en plus
de la prestation normale on a proposé 20
000 ou 30 000 euros d'accord
pour
d'effécation on a proposé 60 000 euros
à l'une 50000 euros à l'autre et le plus
horrible faire l'amour avec un animal
pourquoi
10000 euros d'écart
comme c'est n'importe quoi sans régler
alors
après faire l'amour avec un chameau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de temps en temps
et sinon t'as demandé quoi
non je suis pas dans
d'être ici très content super oui il
vous sortent la dernière tendance
malheureusement c'est des jeunes moi je
sais que Vaiana lui a proposé un tajine
non c'est des jeunes femmes à qui on
propose d'acheter la vie c'est-à-dire de
devenir les esclaves de quelqu'un c'est
des hommes qui dépensent entre 10000
trente mille euros par mois et il
dispose de jeunes femmes quand ils le
veulent ils les mettent dans un
appartement ils peuvent venir les voir
quand ils le veulent et leur imposer des
pratiques délirantes et après sur la
télé je me demande quand même si les
candidats ne sont pas victimes d'une
sorte de délit de sale gueule parce que
la prostitution ça existait avant la
téléréalité les pratiques scatophile ça
existait avant la télé-réalité et je
pense que la télé-réalité en fait c'est
une sorte de société parallèle où il y a
des gens effectivement qui peuvent
peut-être avoir recours à ce genre de
pratique et d'autres qui sont des gens
très sains on a tendance à leur tomber
un peu de sucre parce que c'est des
candidats télé réalité ou des
influenceurs donc voilà faut pas
stigmatiser ces gens là non plus c'est
vrai il y a pas que des escorts
éventuellement des jeunes filles il y a
plein de jeunes filles sur les réseaux
sociaux qui peuvent avoir envie d'une
vie de rêve en tout cas
10 ans de rêve dont on va proposer comme
pour la demoiselle
une semaine pour être pour accompagner
un homme donc elles vont pas imaginer le
pire et effectivement si elles arrivent
là-bas et qu'on leur prend leur
passeport et que elles se font le comité
de réflexion c'est 4 bonhommes et
qu'elle n'ont pas l'occasion de pouvoir
ni bouger voilà donc il faut les
prévenir là-dessus c'est quand même la
maison pendant la pub m'a montré un mail
qu'elle a reçu alors voilà et c'était
écrit en anglais et marqué effectivement
pour être escort c'est 8000 euros la
journée 56000 euros tu seras reçu dans
l'hôtel burjal arabe où il y a une
chambre et tout ça elle m'a montré le
mail à l'instant c'est incroyable ça te
fait plus rien parce que tu reçois
beaucoup 56000 € la semaine donc
effectivement oui il y a quand même
discorting prostitution là moi tout ce
que je voyais à l'époque quand je
faisais de la télé-réalité c'est
qu'effectivement alors c'était pas tout
le temps il y avait deux ou trois jeunes
filles qu'on savait effectivement
c'était des escorts avant et elle
faisait la télé elle servait un petit
peu de nous malheureusement parce que du
coup elle devient effectivement connue
et leur tarifs montent effectivement les
voyez partir à Dubaï après et c'est sûr
que quand tu as été dans les Anges bah
tout d'un coup à Dubaï tu es plus
demandé ton tarif monte et il y a qui
arrive selon la notoriété des escort
aussi des influenceuses et prennent des
comme sur les passes
Dubaï c'est l'histoire de nouvelles
façades de la prostitution c'est le raid
district et les nanas il faut pas croire
qu'elles ont des vies de rêves elles
sont en coloc comme du bétail dans des
petites chambres et après elle pose des
photos hallucinant dans des maisons
hallucinantes dont elles sont pas
propriétaires donc il faut vraiment
faire attention sans juger il faut faire
attention et surtout quand est-ce que
vous avez entendu parler de cette c'est
pratique avec des animaux non sérieux le
chameau déjà moi c'est pas possible
on va pas faire
la technique mais non j'ai jamais
entendu parler de on m'a jamais proposé
en tout cas j'ai jamais entendu parler
franchement je lis même plus moi
toutes les semaines tous les jours donc
tous les jours tous les jours et comment
ils vous trouvent en fait il regarde ça
c'est par contre ça c'est un vrai
mystère
les numéros
des copines à vous qui sont posés la
question qui sont dit c'est vrai que
c'est énormément d'argent est-ce que je
vais pas
avoir à se la poser cette question même
si euh
pour 56000 euros la semaine je reconnais
que tu peux te dire que tu es une jeune
on peut pas avoir le mail et le mail
c'est tu te dis si tu es une jeune fille
c'était juste accompagné un milliardaire
dîner avec
ça merci
les montants sont à la fin
non alors
international à punch man like yours
pour rendez-vous internationaux
international comme vous on paye 8000
euros par jour c'est incroyable oui je
give use
56000 pour la semaine
et ils disent quoi ils disent c'est quoi
pour accompagner
un chauffeur pour vous j'ai un chauffeur
avec une avec une luxueuse voiture pour
50 et vous êtes payé 56000 la semaine
vous êtes dans une tous huit vous avez
un chauffeur avec une voiture de ouf il
vous dit juste de la compagnie des
dégâts comme ça
veut dire voilà
le piège
mais surtout il y a il y a ce que tu
aimerais croire quand tu as besoin
d'argent ouais finalement c'est
peut-être juste pour accompagner tu vas
t'auto convaincre une fois que tu es
dans la chambre et que la porte se ferme
derrière avec deux gardes du corps c'est
terminé c'est fini tu vois ce que je
veux dire et l'autre piège on pourrait
tout c'est tomber enfin moi le premier
je suis pas meilleur que les autres tu
as 20 ans 55000 balles tu viens d'une
famille un petit peu plus simple modeste
bien sûr tu peux tomber dans le piège
élite on sait que c'est une grande
agence de mannequin donc là bien sûr
c'est très important
vous allez voir que c'est quelque chose
de très commun à la prostitution du
Wayne ce qu'on a on a un extrait ça se
fait à la vue de tous regarde
c'est soit des prostituées soit elles
ont le voile soit elles sont des femmes
modernes qui vont au travail c'est ça
donc toutes les filles qui sont escortes
je me suis posé 10 minutes dans un hôtel
le premier mec qui est rentré il m'a
appris il m'a parlé il m'a dit viens on
monte c'est bon 2000 dirhams qui fait
presque 500 € 400 et quelques euros pour
une heure en fait je suis restée 30
minutes avec lui donc vous ça vous
pouvez le faire plusieurs fois dans la
soirée en fait c'est que des
là ça va encore aujourd'hui c'est encore
une très très belle journée il y a très
peu de sur la plage ici c'est de tel ça
marche qu'avec donc sans les ça
marcherait pas du tout
et pour crédibiliser le piège entre
guillemets parfois on propose la voiture
de luxe le chauffeur est aussi j'ai vu
des témoignages où une journée ou deux
de shopping illimité à Dubaï ça se
chiffre en dizaines de milliers d'euros
dans toutes les boutiques dont vous
rêvez les terres les plus grands à Dubaï
et donc la jeune femme un jour shopping
deuxième jour shopping elle est mise en
confiance donc il y a une intoxication
de la jeune femme qui devient plus
Malherbe c'est fou
très jolies prêtes à tout et donc voilà
c'est le monsieur sur la vidéo là et
c'est que des c'est que des mais il est
là lui hein
aujourd'hui c'est que malheureusement
elle est dénoncé de mauvaise manière
comme souvent la jeune fille qui en
parle malheureusement elle s'est mis un
filtre qui voilà tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est tout le premier le plus pour
les gens qui nous rejoignent à 20h50 en
direct Gilles le mode opérateur c'est
quoi on invite ces jeunes filles donc
après quand on leur prend leur papier
alors ça c'est grave tout ça
c'est-à-dire que c'est ça qui est
caractère ce sont des vrais réseaux soit
ce sont des jeunes femmes qui sont comme
on leur dit donnez-nous dans la chambre
d'hôtel elle elle se retrouve elles
viennent pour une soirée avec un
milliardaire une fois qu'elles sont à
Dubaï soit recrutés de l'étranger pour
venir à Dubaï soit aussi sur place on a
décrit des jeunes femmes marchands dans
la rue qui sont accostés par des gens
donc elles sont recrutées pour une
soirée avec un milliardaire mise en
confiance par une journée shopping puis
après donc elles sont invitées un hôtel
elles arrivent dans mortel soit on leur
paye une chambre pour elle comme c'était
le cas dans votre mail soit elle
rejoignent quelqu'un et là plutôt que
d'être avec un homme elles sont face à
quatre ou cinq hommes avec des gardes du
corps parfois on les fait boire il peut
y avoir des drogues dans la boisson et
on va leur prendre leur passeport donc à
Dubaï une fois qu'on vous a pris votre
passeport vous devenez esclavement des
familles ces femmes-là enfin je sais
c'est un film ça moi demain je n'ai pas
de ma mère elle a pas de nouvelles de
moi chercher
ce qu'il faut bien dire aux gens moi
j'ai calculé ton truc et je me suis
225000 euros au mois bien sûr que tu as
envie d'y aller tu dis j'y vais un mois
je reviens ici je m'achète une maison je
m'achète un appart bien sûr que tu as
envie de te dire je vais aller faire une
folie pendant un mois personne ne le
saura c'est moi et ma conscience ce qui
est passé ce qui se passe à Dubaï reste
à Dubaï tu peux penser certaines filles
ça veut dire si je reste deux mois je
prends 500000 balles tu peux ce qu'il a
dit sur l'histoire du passeport c'est là
que les filles doivent faire attention
parce que une fois que tu es là-bas tu
es foutu en comparaison Gilles il peut
me le il peut dire il peut il peut
attester ce que je dis il y a 15 ans des
footballeurs professionnels étaient au
début quand ils sont partis jouer à
Dubaï pour l'argent les présidents de
prenez leur passeport et dites-vous bien
qu'un mec un footballeur professionnel
un homme il était bloqué à Dubaï il
pouvait pas partir les footballeurs
renommés qui avaient joué en Ligue 1 qui
était connu ils étaient bloqué là-bas
ils pouvaient pas partir même des mecs
qu'on joue en équipe de France donc faut
dire aux filles faut pas partir là-bas
comme ça tête baissée en disant je vais
aller prendre 200000 € en un mois parce
que si ils prennent le passeport c'est
terminé tu es dans la merde il y a pas
de ma famille elle va venir ta famille
elle va venir elle va rien faire du tout
le disque parce que vous êtes dans le
réseau c'est fini le réseau vous a
frappé il vous a sorti parfois d'un
environnement précaire comme pour des
jeunes femmes africaines vous êtes là
d'autres aussi de tous les pays des
asiatiques des Européens vous êtes là
vous ne pouvez plus rien faire vous êtes
pris au piège alors vous pouvez refuser
évidemment des pratiques délirantes si
encore vous avez les moyens de refuser
mais vous devenez une fois qu'on est
là-bas est-ce qu'on a le droit de
refaire monsieur vous pouvez refuser oui
vous pouvez refuser les pratiques
scabreuses délirantes mais après les
quatre hommes sont là
témoignages d'une violence absolue
c'est-à-dire pénétration par plein
d'hommes par des objets violences j'ai
même lu un témoignage d'une jeune femme
qui dit j'ai été brutalisé on m'a battu
et pour que je me taise on m'a donné une
mallette en plus vous rendez compte ça
donne une mallette
la mallette était en dollars
bien entendu pas du tout mais c'est une
manière de dire ces gens-là se sont
tellement en impunité voilà on t'a battu
en cette mallette et tais-toi ce qui est
fou et puis là-bas qu'elle recourt vous
avez honnêtement
ça existe après faut pas non plus
stigmatiser Dubaï il y a pas que des
prostituées à Dubaï parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe c'est qu'une jeune femme
sur Instagram connu ou pas connu elle
met une photo à Dubaï c'est ah tu es une
escorte il y a pas que ça et pardon il y
a pas besoin d'aller à Dubaï pour voir
des prostituées il y en a aussi en
France partout des pratiques comme ça il
y en a aussi en France donc voilà je
pense il y a aussi des gens qui
travaillent à Dubaï et qui gagnent bien
leur vie et qui réussissent qui vient de
se suicider d'ailleurs à cause de toutes
ces rumeurs parce que justement elle
était connue à Dubaï et qu'il y avait
des propose de Cyril heure là elle a pas
supporté et elle s'est suicidé donc je
pense qu'il faut faire attention